Gabi or joins us now she's a White House
reporter for Politico Gabi good morning
good morning as we heard Jill
Schlesinger say this is a Goldilocks
report for the for the White House
that's great news so how do the
Democrats campaign against an economy
that looks this good well you know as we
just heard they will remind people that
at some point this will eventually turn
to a recession and that's something that
the president needs to be worried about
concerned about and that their policies
would somehow prevent that or at least
curb the results of a recession if they
got into office at the same time we're
hearing them talk a lot about income
inequality that even though the economy
is soaring right now and that the
president would normally be coasting
toward reelection that there are several
Americans I mean groups pockets across
the country that are still suffering
tremendously in poverty in poverty and
from low wages and so that even you know
even as we look at these economic
numbers is we look at GDP over three
percent growth as the Dow reaches its
record high there are still Americans
that are suffering and the Democrats are
gonna be arguing that their policies
would do a better job of addressing
those concerns how concerned are our
Republicans that the president may not
stay on message when it comes to this
fabulous economy right now is he
campaign probably very concerned because
if you go and look at what happened
before the midterm elections that was
the biggest issue for a lot of
Republicans they wanted the president to
talk about nothing but the GOP tax bill
the economy and all he talked about was
immigration he focused on those caravans
that were coming last fall and we're
sort of seeing him trend in that
direction right now as well he's been
tweeting up a storm about the Moller
report lately he's been talking about
immigration as well he's been doing
trips to the border he's been sending
his staff to do the trips to the border
he's focusing on issues that are so
divisive and when he really should be
according to his advisors talking up
these numbers I mean under normal
circumstances this is an economy that
would have a president coasting toward a
landslide election and because he's
focusing on a lot of these other issues
his advisers his campaign staff are
really worried and urging him not to and
we still have the malla report you heard
and Steve Dorsey's report the House
Judiciary Committee Chairman Jerry
Nadler zas 'king for an unredacted
Muller report do you think that that's
likely to happen is this a political
move because I mean most of it was
released we've seen
most of what's in the contents of that
report it depends on who you ask mean
the Justice Department is arguing that
they will release some of the grand jury
information that they will release a
lesser redacted report to Congress but
that a fully unredacted report with all
of the underlying evidence and material
and grand jury material as well it's
just not something that needs to be
handed over and that they feel at least
that House Democrats and the Oversight
Committee has it provided a legitimate
reason for needing those documents
of course there's negotiations ongoing
between the Justice Department and
chairman Nadler he essentially gave an
ultimatum to the Attorney General
yesterday saying that if you don't
provide some type of unredacted version
or less lesser redacted version that we
will hold you in contempt of Congress
and I think we're gonna see whether that
happens next week didn't Watergate show
them though if they went towards
impeachment they would have more power
to get the documents that they're going
after wouldn't they they would but at
the same time I mean look at the polling
around impeachment right now Democrats
are being very careful and I think
that's why we're seeing a shift toward
sort of demonizing the Attorney General
and way more so than the president
there's a sort of a proxy attack on the
president in effect it is and it's not
really you know if you look at the
impeachment numbers I think it's about
57 56 percent of Americans who don't
want them to go down that path but if
you look at what happened just last week
with with the Attorney General I mean he
essentially contradicted his own
testimony to Congress and that's
something that they can seize on that
they can use to sort of say well this is
just another corrupt trump
administration official and not really
go after the president specifically
Gabby thank you so much thank you